well as a number of factors that have
improved the underlying position of the
public finances and some that have made
it worse but it's better on balance
overall the biggest single one is that
it looks like the government is going to
have to spend less money on interest
payments on its debt main reason for
that is that the interest rates in
financial markets which governments can
borrow have fallen since our last
forecast in July and so that saves them
about 18 billion pounds over the course
of the of the five years there's also
going to change the Bank of England as
announced recently that it's likely to
reverse quantitative easing a bit later
than previously been anticipated that
saves money on debt interest as well
there's also been some good news in
areas of tax receipts we've had income
tax and corporation tax coming a little
bit better than we'd expected so far
this year we're a bit more optimistic
about the outlook for national insurance
and v80 over the next few years then you
also have factors that have pushed in
the other direction share prices are
lower than they were in July and that
loses your money on things like
inheritance tax capital gains tax we're
less confident as well about the pace at
which houses are going to be bought and
sold and that loses you stamp duty as
well so there are things going in both
directions but on balance it is an
improvement the improvement is
concentrated in the middle years of the
Parliament though so it looks less good
as you get to the end and that's why the
chance does had to rely more on tax
increases rather than you know just this
underlying improvement to get the bottom
line better at the end 27 7 billion
pounds is a big figure though how did
you get it so wrong before well this is
this is the forecast over the five years
so this is not a comparison to an out
turn number that we've already seen as I
say partly it's things like and this
happens in both directions between every
forecasts that we do when you have
market interest rates changing the
interest rates of which governments can
borrow money then that can make a big
difference a quite small movement that
if you have a mortgage you probably
don't think of as very big can add up to
a lots of billions of pounds if you're
if you're a government that's for the
biggest single measure there's a lot at
stake here though isn't there what
happens if you're wrong well any central
forecast there's a fifty percent chance
we think things are going to be better a
fifty percent chance things are going to
be worse normally with budgets obviously
any chance they're doing a budget or an
autumn statement knows
there's another one coming along in a
few months time and you can adjust your
policies accordingly this is obviously
slightly different we're dealing with a
spending review here and that's setting
out firm plans for government department
I mean Chancellor's bedroom that money
is named and that's harder to change
that if you if you want to later on
although not impossible so I think from
the Chancellor's point of view he needs
to set policy aware that any given
forecast like this could be wrong in
either direction and you want to be
robust to those risks on both sides yeah
and add at the end of the day is a
decision for him to take what risks not
for us well based on past performance do
you think you're being over optimistic
and perhaps the Chancellor should have
been more cautious with the forecast
that you've given him well by definition
the forecast we've produced is a central
forecast we think it's equally likely
that things will turn out better equally
light so do you think he's a big see
much no as I say on the basis of the
numbers that we've put out he's giving
himself scope to achieve the fiscal
targets that he set himself with a bit
of room for manoeuvre he's aiming for
example for a budget surplus about about
10 billion pounds at the end of the
Parliament history suggests if you look
at the errors in official forecast hours
and the Treasuries over many years that
probably gives him about a fifty-five
percent chance of actually delivering a
surplus in that year so it's by no means
a done deal but there's a little bit of
room for manoeuvre for things to go
wrong things could turn out better as
well Robert J thank you